Speaker 1: All right. Many of you wrote
in about my coverage yesterday of Bobby
Kennedy Jr's candidacy. The reactions were
all over the map. People saying, David,
you're wrong. This is God's gift to politics
or David, you're wrong. He's way worse than
what you're saying. He actually has no redeeming
qualities and you're not being tough enough on
Bobby Kennedy Jr. Maybe because you know him.
I know him. I sat with him at a dinner once
and then people who said, I appreciated you
giving some context about Bobby Kennedy Jr.
I want to be super clear. The negatives
about bobby Kennedy jr are single handedly
disqualifying of him as an even remotely serious
presidential candidate. And I'm going to give you
examples today. So I'm not going to be wishy
washy and act like, well, there's pros and
cons and maybe they cancel out, so maybe you'll
vote for the guy. No, what I'm telling you is,
although there are some things about him that
I like. There are concerns so bad that they are
uniquely disqualifying. I'm going to give you one
example. Okay. Tonight. Tonight, Bobby Kennedy Jr
is hosting a so-called health policy roundtable.
You can RSVP and participate if you want. Okay.
This health policy roundtable is being held
with dangerous vectors of disinformation,
many of whom we've covered on the program
already. These are not just, you know, folks
with slightly different views about vaccination or
whatever. These are dangerous and in some cases,
seemingly certifiably insane lunatics. And hosting
a health policy roundtable with these people
is single handedly disqualifying. Take a look at
this. Mr. Kennedy will meet with leading critics
of truly paroling health policy, including Dr. Joe
Mercola, Dr. Sherri Tenpenny, Dr. Pierre Kory, Dr.
Patrick, Gun Tempo, Maureen McDonald, Del Bigtree,
Mickey Willis and Sayer G. Let's go back to Sherri
Tenpenny in a moment. Okay. These people, many of
whom we've talked about before. Joseph Mercola is
a widely known purveyor of pseudoscience and
conspiracy theories find by the FDA for making
false and misleading claims about his products
and COVID 19 treatments. Dangerous. Not a serious
person. Okay. Pierre Cary advocates for the
use of ivermectin as a COVID treatment or cure,
despite the fact that there's no actual randomized
controlled trials showing that that works. Patrick
Denton Bo chiropractor and entrepreneur who made
an Anti-vaxx documentary. That's who Bobby Kennedy
is meeting with. Maureen MacDonald, holistic
health educator who is anti-vaccine spread,
spreads, false information about vaccines. Every
single one of these people, Del Bigtree founded
an anti-vaccine group, produces propaganda movies.
Mickey Willis, activist who also promotes vaccine
disinformation, has been denounced by serious
medical experts. So all of these people and then,
of course, Sherri Tenpenny, if the name Sherri
Tenpenny rings a bell, it's because we've talked
about her before. Here is self-described vaccine
expert Sherri Tenpenny, explaining that this year,
this year, folks, it's almost July and it hasn't
happened this year. Every one of us will have five
or even ten people we know dead from the vaccine.
Speaker 3: Now we're seeing the tsunami of deaths
that I've been talking about since the beginning
of 21. Right. Millions of people are going to die,
you know, And Judy Mikovits came out on
Plandemic at the beginning of that and said that
that more than 50 million people are going
to die. And everybody was like, Whoa.
And when they started interviewing me and I and
they asked me, what did I think about that number,
I said, It's way too low. It's going to be much
more than 50 million people in America. Wow.
And we're already starting to see it.
Speaker 1: We're not.
Speaker 3: So the tsunami of deaths is
coming. It's already here. And i believe.
Speaker 1: Remember bobby kennedy
Jr. Is having an event tonight with
this woman as if she is an expert on health.
Speaker 3: What's happening now and this is
starting to happen now is the tsunami of regrets
of the people that fell for the lies, the fear,
friends and family members and parents and
children and all they did to your grandchildren
just could not be told otherwise. But now
that people are dying like flies, I mean,
my business partner has 83 close
people in his life that have died.
Speaker 1: I don't even believe her
business. Partner has 83 close people
in his life. Never mind 83 people that have died.
Speaker 3: 83. It's the beginning. And I predict
that by the end of this year, every person in
this room and every person listening behind
here is going to know a minimum of five,
probably ten or more, close friends and
family members that have died from these shots.
Speaker 1: Okay. I still we're almost in July.
Now, I understand we've got half of the year
left. I don't know a single person that's died
of the vaccine and everybody I know is vaccinated.
That's who Bobby Kennedy is having an event with.
One more Sherry tenpenny clip just to really drive
home how insane this is. Here she says that it's
vaccinating kids is a form of child sacrifice.
Speaker 3: This is happening in America, people.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: And it's your job to stop everybody,
you know, and wake them up and shove it in their
face. And if they defund you off of social media,
who cares? Now it's about trying to save unborn
babies and pregnant women. It's about that they
now are actually starting a trial and
to give these shots to six month olds.
This is child sacrifice. This is the
resurgence of child sacrifice from
the days of the Babylonian Missouri schools.
Speaker 1: And then she goes into a religious
nonsense. All right, folks. So, listen,
I think it's great that Bobby Kennedy
wants a higher minimum wage and wants to deal
with homelessness. And whatever this event,
this event is uniquely disqualifying. Let's dig
in now a little more into his view on vaccines.